BALLS AROUND IN THE BINGO
MACHINE, AND HOPING TO GET YOUNG
TALENT IF Y UNDER THE PROTOCOL,
AND SET TO RETURN AS YOU
MENTIONED.
THE PENGUGURE BY PITTSBURGH.
LETANG WITH A PASS DOWN LOW.
GREAT SAVE BY IS ZUCKER
RIGHT IN, AND STOPPED BY
GUSTAVSSON, AND
PICKED BY McGINN AND McGINN
ON THE BACKHAND ANDND HANDFUL, D
VETERAN PLAYER, AND Z Z CHABOT
ON THE RUSH, AND CIRCLE IN
BEHIND, AND TRIED TO WRAP AROUND
>> WITH THE MAN ADVANTAGE AND A
CHANCE TO GO TO WORK HERE, AND .
BUT TRYING TO GET LATE PRESSURE
HERE.
RODRIGUES GETS A SHOT AWAY AND
CHABOT IN FRONT. AND SECOND CHA,
AND SCORES!
[CROWD NOIOIROUND
THE WALL, A A
THE TRAILER, CHABOT TO THE TOP
OF THE CIRCLE WITH A SHOT AND
THAT WAS BLOCKED BYER.
TIERNEY GETS THE PUCK AGAIN.
NOW HEATHERER MEANTIME,
THEY SCORE OFTEN THE FACEOFF!
.
HE HAS A GOAL TONIGHT, I DON'T
THINK HE GETS AN ASSIST AOCKED Y
SCORE!
PENGUIN, AND IT'S THE SEN IT ACE
BACKHAND, AND SHARPRP
STUTZLE PASSING.
SHOOTING.
SCORING! PASS TO THE FORECHECKE.
>> EFFORTLESS, AND A LITTLE
MOVE.
[CROWD NOISE] ENNIS
TO RECOGNIZE THAT BATHERSON'S
COMING.
I'M NOT SURE IF BATHERSON IS BA.
SCORES!
[CROWD NOISE]
SENATORS HAVE
HERE'S BLUEGER.OOD JOB OF
HAS McGINN IN FRONT, SCORE!
OFF THE POST AND IN.
AS RODRIGUES LETS IT RIP.
[CROWD NWITH IT, AND DRIVE MATHD
SIEFED OUT FRONT, AND ALL THE R.
HIS SECOND OF THE PERIOD.
[CROWD
ONE-TIMER SPOT, AND THEY SAW
NET.
SCORES!
[HORN]
SENATORS.
WHO HAVE PLAYED A FABULOUS GAME.